Donald sterling we now all know what
happened so let's just fast-forward and
go to what happened yesterday which was
Adam silver the new NBA commissioner
laying down the hammer let's go to the
videotape immediately I am banning mr.
sterling for life from any association
with the Clippers organization or the
NBA mr. sterling
may not attend any NBA games or
practices he may not be present at any
Clippers facility and he may not
participate in any business or player
personnel decisions involving the team
he will also be barred from attending
NBA Board of Governors meetings or
participating in any other league
activity
I am also finding mr. sterling 2.5
million dollars the maximum amount
allowed under the NBA constitution okay
so if you were hiding under a rock 10
second recap Donald sterling owner of
the Clippers 9 minute audiotape
incredibly racist while talking to his
black and Mexican girlfriend we'll get
to that part in just a second I mean
there's so many layers of this let's
just start with just broad racism it's
it hasn't gone anywhere has it no Isis
Abama got elected I think it's pretty
much kinda the closet so if we have a
little dip when Obama came in was there
a little dip and a feeling like maybe
we're getting past this and we're
post-racial and now it's starting to
rear its ugly head again do you think
that's what's going on no yeah I think
we for 10 seconds when Obama got a bomb
ax got elected that was that was amazing
but I mean the fact that the guy was
black and had this weird name I thought
there's no way America is going for this
and they did it was great but yeah it
then it just pushed all the buttons and
all of the fear of the white males who
are losing the battle
sorry guys
had a good run and yeah it's it's now
it's now seeping out of every corner of
our culture so his weird name are you
saying that's why they always say Barack
Hussein Obama they do that
Rick racism did but I thought we were
past it but I guess not huh
well shows you how smarter racist is -
hey I'm in charge of hey I'm done I'm in
charge of a whole team hi come on down
to my Ford dealership but unless you're
Asian pull him out of there hey come on
down to the bathhouse unless you're gay
this guy he's not a very bright guy he
wasn't destined to be anything but
briefly lucky yeah would you guys feel
slightly different if he didn't have
this crazy history of racism you know
Elgin Baylor the former GM of the
Clippers had gotten into him
gotten into some stuff with him there's
been this slumlord issue that he didn't
want black and Hispanic people renting
his apartments if this had been somebody
that had a perfectly clean record as far
as we knew would you feel different
about a private phone call absolutely
and there is an issue around the privacy
of that phone calling Kareem
abdul-jabbar wrote a great little piece
I think for Time magazine online and he
talked about that part of it that he
didn't like that part of it but yeah it
might have been like a Michael Richards
moment or something for Donald sterling
I mean who knows but the point that
Kareem abdul-jabbar made and these other
people is if this guy's been doing this
for years and years
he's known he has a reputation in the
city for being like this and no one made
a fuss about it then so but it takes
something like this you know a TMZ
moment in our culture to actually push
to push him over the edge this new media
we have that you know they're
discounting as oh that's just the
alternate media or that's just citizen
journalism as having gargantuan
sledgehammer impact on circumstances
there was the kid who had Alzheimer's in
school was being bullied so even
Asperger's as Berger said he was in
school and he records the the bullies
and they sue him and so the
the mass media took over and they
dropped the suit and they ran and hid
yeah and there's some other
circumstances like that aren't there
it's powerful but it is also there is an
issue I mean you know this was a private
phone call and I guess the girlfriend
today and when the in the LA Times the
girlfriend was saying that she did not
mean for this to go out and she did not
release it but there was a third party
involved we don't know who that is yet
who did release it so do you guys fear
that that the privacy thing about we
talk about privacy at some level every
week on they shown we're gonna do more
of it in a little bit but that the
privacy thing has completely disappeared
because we've all said things privately
in private conversations we're all in
the comedy world where you joke about
things that you do it publicly and it
can be taken the wrong way much less if
you did it privately so do you worry
about that that we're losing that at all
which in no way is a defense of anything
he said on in that audiotape obviously I
don't think that we're yeah and we're
talking about two different things I'm
afraid of losing other kinds of things
over that system entirely then just I
said the wrong thing in a joke I think
we may have given up more freedom than
that for this artificial safety in that
system I'd I'm not sure if there's any
real safety at all and and what they
provide us with this security sister I
don't think America well I don't think
they're even referring at all to our
individual safety when they're recording
they're wondering when we're gonna wise
up and come out and do something I think
in general though I don't think we've
really had the privacy conversation yet
I think we're all experimenting with
this stuff and I mean look at social
media we we give away all of our privacy
in order to connect to people on
Facebook and Twitter in all those places
you know you sign it away when you when
you download the app and so we all know
that we've really even begun to have a
real conversation about I don't think I
don't think the average person it's hid
their life yet yeah and when that does
then the conversation will really start
oh we're trying to do it here which is
why I bring it up every week do you guys
to me it seems like the NBA did
absolutely the right thing Adam silver
brand-new guy you know David Stern
somewhere in July or not they did the
right thing you know pump for publicity
because of obviously this has been going
on before and they knew about it before
it was okay before until this
form of media got hold of it and aimed
it like a set of guns on him and they
recognized that we have a set of
controls to shoot at them with words and
they're terrified of these words and
they even said that they they've been
wanting to take action against him for a
while but they had they watch these
lawsuits go down and the lawsuits kept
going down in his favor so they really
couldn't make the move and my
understanding is if he hadn't done what
he did yesterday every single team was
gonna walk off the court last night yeah
which would be really fun I mean even if
they just delayed the games a half hour
and heat up the TNT ESPN
it was the advertisers that motivated
most of this you know board members long
oak table pounding fists you know well
did you guys see the the video of the
advertisers at Staples Center they were
literally covering up advertisers their
billboards with the Virgin America seats
were going away what kind of racist has
a black girlfriend we've been talking a
lot about this on The Young Turks
so what's going on there with that
mentality that you could have a black
girlfriend and then you could say to
this girl
do not bring black magic Johnson forget
the racist part if you know any if you
care at all about basketball you would
want to be associated with he's an
amazing guy yeah it really how do you
how do you guys parse that level of race
well you know that that kind of racism
in general is fear of the other it's a
it's a it's your unconscious psyche
afraid of the thing the unknown the
thing that you can't control and the
thing that that is so different from you
that you can't recognize it and it leaks
out in personalities in all sorts of
interesting ways so having a black or
Latino girlfriend you can [ __ ] her you
know so you can have control over her
you can sexually dominate her that's one
way to deal with the other the unknown
and the other is then to try to control
you know your public space and here's a
man clearly a ton of money you look at
the LA Times ads this guy takes out one
Sam
you know touting him oh I've got another
award with this I would have total
narcissist he wants to control his
kingdom and that's one way another way
of dealing with it I'm going to control
my space and you get to come in and you
don't I mean it's it's it's actually not
as strange as it looks
yeah is it also sort of that plantation
mentality like you know we can have I
could have the the black girl in the
house and I don't have to show any love
yep she's just a utility to me ya know
it's like that's a great analogy for
sure yeah actually the last question on
this do you think the MBA should force
him to sell because that's the one thing
they haven't done at this point and
there are some questions as far as
legality because they're their bylaws
are in public so you know maybe the
owners would have to vote on it do you
think they should force it just to
really put the final stamp on this I
guess so I don't know much about that
world but what is he gonna do what
choice does he really have where he's
not welcome yeah yeah can't show up to
the games anyway so you can't do
anything what's the point all right well
hopefully he sells